Good morning.
The title of today's lecture is home town boy honoring an emperors roots in
Roman North Africa.
And who was that hometown boy?
We met him before we met him in the last lecture.
His name was Lucius Septimius severities and he was emperor of Rome between one
93 and two 11 a d.
And we saw him in this extraordinary round painting on wood,
uh,
that comes from Egypt and is now in the museum in Berlin.
That depicts Lucia Septum,
me saveras with his family.
You see September you severity on the right hand side of the screen.
You see his wife,
Julia,
Donna on the left with her famous wigs and pearls,
wig and pearls.
And then down below their two sons gate,
a carer color over here on the right and gator who's faced has been a race
because of the dog,
not too memoria that was voted him by the Senate at his death.
We learned that Julia Domino's came from Syria.
She was the wife,
she was the daughter of a priest by the name of bossiness and Septimius severity
came from North Africa.
He was the third Roman emperor to be from somewhere other than Italy.
You'll recall that Trajan and Hadrian came from Spain.
Cep to me is severity from North Africa and after he ascended to the throne,
uh,
and after he began his,
his reign and with all the interesting things that he initiated as emperor,
he was honored by his hometown,
his hometown boys often are,
and the city of lept is Magdna was renovated quite sick quite significantly
during his reign.
And it's to that renovation and to the history of leftist Maga in general and
its architecture that I want to turn today.
Before I do that,
however,
it's important for us to get a sense of this part of the world,
this part of the world before the Romans took over.
Uh,
and any of you who are working on term papers that are on,
uh,
works of architecture in the provinces or are designing a Roman city in anywhere
other than Italy,
have definitely found out that in order to analyze those,
in order to think about them and figure out what's happening,
you have to not only look at what's going on in the center of the Empire that is
in Rome and what may have been sent from the center out to the periphery,
but you also have to understand what was going on in the local area in which
that building was built,
the local culture,
the civilizations that proceeded the Roman civilization.
Uh,
and what's fascinating about provincial Roman architecture is the way in which
those two things come together.
That is what comes from Rome to the frontiers,
but also the indigenous culture that mixes with what comes from Rome to make
something unique in the case of each of these provinces.
So it's absolutely critical for us to understand,
uh,
the area that we're looking at it,
in this case,
a Roman north Africa before the Romans got to,
uh,
the north northern part of Africa.
Uh,
it was an area that was overseeing primarily by Carthage.
There was a very significant Carthaginian period in this part of the world.
Uh,
the language was a neo Punic and burbur before it was Latin and neo Punic stays
on even when Latin becomes important.
Here there was,
the Greeks did have some impact,
but they didn't have as strong a foothold in this particular part of the world
as they did elsewhere.
And then eventually the area is colonized by Rome and begins to be,
and Roman colonies begin to be built here.
Uh,
it all over the northern part of Africa.
I show you here a map of the western empire where we see,
uh,
not only places that we've already studied Rome and Ostia and palm pay,
but also down here,
uh,
the continent of Africa.
You see it here.
Uh,
and the cities that we're going to be talking about,
there was lots of,
there were lots of Roman cities in this part of the world,
but the two that we're going to be focusing on today are the city of Tim Gad,
which you see over here.
And then the city of lept is Magdna.
And please note while the map is on the screen,
that lept is Magdna is right on the coast.
In fact,
it was an extremely important seaport,
which is one of the reasons that it grew,
grew in to,
to the size and significance that it did have in ancient times.
Tim Gat a little bit further into the mainland of North Africa.
And you can also see of course the relationship when you think of is Magdna as a
port.
You can see the relationship,
the easy relationship in the sense that it had to other major ports in Roman
times,
specifically Ostia and how,
how easy it clearly was a descend things from one place to another,
which again led,
uh,
to the efflorescence of Leptin is Magdna.
Now,
the reason I've chosen these particular cities,
we're going to be talking primarily about Leptin is today.
But the reason that I've also chosen to look at Tim Gat is because they make a
very interesting contrast to one another.
Both of them have extraordinarily WellPreserved Roman remains,
but they're interesting to play off against one another.
Because the city of leftist modern,
and this is extremely important in analyzing it,
the city of lept is Magdna had a longer Roman history.
It was already,
uh,
we it to had a Carthaginian period.
Uh,
but most important in this regard was the fact that the Romans began to build.
They're already in the first century.
BC is,
we shall see.
It was built up under Augustus,
then under Hadrian,
a renovated under Septicemia Savara.
So there's not only the local,
the local,
uh,
structures and buildings and,
and customs and so on to contend with,
but also earlier Roman architecture.
By the time we get to the time of September,
the severity,
in the case of Tim Gad,
the city was built entirely from scratch.
There was nothing on the site when Trajan founded the city.
As a Roman colony in 100 and 100 Aad and it was at that time that the Romans
laid out their ideal plan.
And what we're looking at here is a view from the air of Tim Gad as it would've
looked after.
It was laid out by Trajan in 100 as it continues to look today,
we are looking down from the air and we see here one of the best examples that I
have been able to show you this semester of the way in which the Romans,
when they are left to their own devices,
when there are no earlier,
uh,
structures that they need to contend with,
no earlier customs on the site,
earlier temples and the like that they need to contend with.
This is what they do when they build their ideal Roman city.
And you can see it as exactly as we described it in the mid fourth century BC at
Ostia.
That is a costume plan.
It's laid out like a military camp,
very regular,
either rectangular or square as you see it here it is surrounded by city walls.
It has the two main streets,
the carto and the deck.
You Montas exactly in the center of the city,
intersecting with one another at the center of the city.
And then right at that intersection as was customary for Roman town planning of
this cost from type,
they have placed the forum right at the intersection of those two and you can
see it here also from the air.
The forum has a great open rectangular space.
It has a basilica,
it has a temple on one short,
and I'm not going to show you that,
uh,
that forum in any deep,
I'm not going to show it to you at all except for what you see here.
But it is very,
it is a similar to others that we've seen.
We can also see from the air,
the theater of the city of Leptin is a city of Tim gap also taking it's
customary shape.
Uh,
and in this case,
again,
very close to the forum.
But as you look at the rest of this from the air,
you can see again,
not only is it a regular is the whole city irregular shape,
but it has been laid out within the city,
uh,
in very regular into lie or blocks with the streets.
Very straight as again,
the Romans were want to do the city of Tim.
God,
by the way,
is located in the high plains of what is Algeria today,
just for you to get your bearings in terms of,
uh,
the modern location of this city.
What,
what I hope you can also see from this view,
from the air,
if you look very,
very closely at the individual streets,
and especially this one right here,
you will see perhaps it's clearest over here.
You will see that one of the ways in which this however differs from a town like
Ostia and the way Osteo was laid out is although the general layout is
comparable,
the city streets are lined with columns.
We talked about the fact that colonated streets,
we never see colonated streets in Rome or in Italy,
but we do see them quite extensively in the provinces.
This is a,
this is a,
an area that is part of the western provinces,
but we see them also even more extensively in the eastern provinces.
So you see this colonated,
it's very dramatic,
uh,
colonated street and I can show you a detail of one of the colonated streets of
the city of Tim Gad as it looks today.
And you can see the effect that putting those columns,
the punctuation points of those columns along the way,
which actually adds to it makes the Vista,
uh,
that one sees from one part of the street to another.
Uh,
very,
very interesting and deed as those columns in the sense of March toward the arch
that you see at the end here.
I'm going to show you that arch just as the one example of a monument in the
city of Leptin is Magdna.
It's very well preserved.
It's usually called the arch of Trajan because Trajan was the one to have
founded this particular city.
But it is almost certainly not an arch of Trajan since we believe it was put up
in the late second century a d.
But we still call it the arch of Trajan cause that's it's conventional name.
Uh,
and I can show you a detail of that arch as it looks today on the screen.
And I think it's interesting to compare it to another in this case,
early third century arch,
the arch of September,
he is severity in the Roman forum,
put up to September [inaudible] Parthian victories in the eastern part of the
empire that we looked at last time.
And I think you'll see immediately why I've chosen to pair those two,
not only because they're roughly comparable in date,
but because both of them have,
uh,
a triple bay triple bays is central,
a very central,
large archi weighted bay to smaller RQ weighted Bay's one on either side.
And since the building that you see here,
we believe dates to the late second century Aad.
And this building is not until the early third century ID two oh three,
two oh three had to be precise.
It is another example.
I mentioned this last time.
I talked about the fact that the arch in the Roman forum,
the Archer Septimius Severus and the Roman forum is our first uh,
preserved Roman arch with a triple RQ weighted bay in Rome.
Uh,
but that there are,
there is,
there was an earlier example that I showed you in the south of France at a place
called old wrongs and what is now provost,
uh,
where we seem to have a tie Berian arch,
a Tiberian arch that is also triple Bates.
So I raised the,
the point with you that it,
that while we usually think of ideas flowing from the center to the periphery,
uh,
this may be an instance where certain ideas are developed first in the provinces
and then make their way to Rome.
Or it is also possible that there may have been triple RQ weighted arches in
Rome that no longer survive today,
that we don't know about.
That might have been earlier than the early third century.
But the fact that here we have another example in one of the province is a
completely different part of the world,
but,
uh,
the western province is nonetheless,
we have another example of a triple archi weighted bay arch,
uh,
that was put up prior to the arch of Septimius Rivera's in the Roman forum.
So it just,
it just,
uh,
it just makes us think even more so,
that,
that this idea was floating around the empire earlier,
clearly than the time of Septimius Riveras and makes it more possible that the
idea may have begun in the,
in,
in the provinces rather than in Rome itself.
The other major difference between this arch and the arch of Septimius
severities and the Roman forum,
well,
there are two,
uh,
but the main one is that it relies for the most part for its effects where it's
visual effects on its architect tonic elements on its columns,
on its niches,
on its pediments,
uh,
the arch of septicemia severity in Rome,
yes,
has projected and columns and the like,
but it relies for its effects largely on the figural sculpture that decorates
it.
The decorates the panels over each of the smaller bays,
the freeze and so on and so forth.
That is not true here.
This may have had some sculpture.
It probably had a group,
a quad [inaudible] quad drug group or a group of statues on the attic.
It probably had a statue or two in these niches,
but it has no relief sculpture,
no figural relief sculpture at all.
And realize instead,
as I said,
on the architectural elements to enliven the surface and to make it an
interesting billboard,
uh,
for,
whoever this was put up to commemorate.
We see,
for example,
these large,
uh,
Corinthian columns on tall basis,
the basis or not decorated.
Uh,
and we also see if we look very carefully,
uh,
that there were,
um,
there were smaller columns,
there are capital still preserved on either side of the niches of,
there were smaller columns here as well.
An interesting contrast between the larger columns and the smaller columns.
And then if you look very closely at the pediment above,
you see that it is an RQ pediment.
Sometimes these are referred to as segmental,
segmental or RQ weighted pediments.
And you can see that it is not only an RQ weighted pediment,
but it's a broken RQ,
weighted pediment.
Uh,
it has been,
the bottom is not complete.
It's broken on either side.
We've seen an increasing tastes with these broken triangular,
a segmental pediments enrollment architecture.
This willingness to break the rules of traditional,
uh,
traditional columnar architecture.
We see that here.
So again,
it is the surface is enlivened,
uh,
through architectural means entirely,
which is,
uh,
an interesting phenomenon for this part of the world.
You can also see,
I think that the stone that is used here is a local limestone,
a wonderful tan color that goes very well with the desert area in which this
finds itself.
So local stone used the so called arch of Titus in the city of Tim Gad.
I talked about the sand and there's a lot of sand in this part of the world.
This is essentially a desert,
uh,
and we see it,
especially around the city of leftist Magnar,
Leptos Magdna.
If Tim Gad is in modern,
Algeria,
lept is Magdna is in modern Libya,
Colonel Kadafi country.
And uh,
it is an amazing site.
A few words about the history of leftist magna prior to the birth of September
is severity.
Uh,
it too,
well,
it was,
as I mentioned,
a port city,
uh,
it was a Phoenician port actually initially.
Then it came under the sway of Carthage of the Carthaginians.
Uh,
it had some interactions with Greece,
but again,
I just as a,
this area as a whole,
and this part of the part of Africa,
uh,
that we,
that leapt a smog is located in is,
was known as Triphala Tanea Triphala,
Tanea.
And,
uh,
so we,
we see the Carthaginians holding sway.
We see some interactions with Greece,
but again,
it doesn't take as significant a foothold here as it did in other parts of the
Roman world.
And then Rome,
Rome takes over.
Leptin is Magdna.
It makes,
it,
makes it a colony.
It makes the area colony for Pelotonia.
Tanium it's a colony.
And,
uh,
it begins to be built up,
as I mentioned to you before already in the late republic and into the Augustan
period,
we'll see that there was significant Augusta in architecture there that still
survives.
Uh,
it was then,
uh,
that architecture was added to by Hadrian,
or during the period of Hadrian during the time during the reign of Hadrian when
there was a continued interest in leftist Magnar.
And,
uh,
then it was built up,
and renovated significantly under Septum,
Mya Savara.
So in the early third century,
a d it continued to thrive throughout the third century,
into the fourth century,
a d,
but in the fifth century,
a d it was attacked,
significant attack by the vandal tribes.
Uh,
it was,
it was devastated actually during that period at butted had a brief renascence
under the Byzantines,
uh,
a Byzantine wall was added to the city as well as a church.
Uh,
during that period in medieval and modern times,
though it was essentially abandoned and it became a place where treasure hunters
did not,
did not hesitate to go and take stone and works of sculpture a away with them.
But fortunately because of these sands,
because these sands shifted over time with the winds,
with the Shiroko and so on,
they eventually did,
w did their job by covering over a good part of the city,
which was actually fortunate because it meant that everything that hadn't
already been looted by those treasure hunters was at that point preserved.
It stayed covered for the most part until around World War II.
Uh,
at that time in the 20th century,
uh,
for Triphala,
Tanea was essentially a protectorate of Italy.
Uh,
and in right at the time of World War II and right after World War II,
uh,
Italian archeologists went in and excavated the site and revealed it in the way
that we can experience it.
If we visit a leftist Magdna today,
and if we visit [inaudible] today,
we're going to see sights like this.
What I'm showing you is a view from the air of the forum that was put up in the
time upset to me is severity.
The so called Severen forum I've left is Magnar.
And you can see that this is,
uh,
another one of these bigger is better buildings.
It's extraordinarily large.
Uh,
and you can see that it has a,
that it is not in the best of conditions.
Then much of it has fallen down.
We see extensive fragments of columns,
uh,
and um,
an tablatures and arcades and so on and so forth strewn around,
uh,
the structure today.
But there's enough there that we can get a quite good sense as we shall see of
what these buildings looked like in antiquity.
If one goes to the sculpture depot on the site,
one can also see a host of sculpture despite the,
the,
the looting one can also see a host of sculpture that still survives.
In fact,
it's interesting,
right in the center here we see a portrait of Joe.
Who is it,
sorry to put you on the spot,
but having taken Roman,
it's Augustus.
Good.
Excellent.
It's the emperor Augustus right there in the center,
which proves,
or which tends to make it likely,
uh,
to,
to support,
uh,
the point,
that,
uh,
this was an area that was built up under Augustus and decorated with Augustan
sculpture.
We see a host of statues,
women,
uh,
fragments of a body parts including hands and arms,
as you can see over here at the depot.
And uh,
this again gives us some general sense of how a heavily decorated the this town
was in its hay day with sculpture of the imperial family,
surely and uh,
and uh,
local magistrates as well as gods and goddesses.
This is a plan of a leftist Magnar as it would have looked in the ancient
period.
Uh,
we are,
if we look at it here,
we will see number one that it is,
you can tell very well from this.
And it was a port city and the airport was built.
You seeing,
uh,
the,
um,
the Mediterranean,
then you're seeing a,
a tributary of that river,
uh,
and you can see right below that river,
you can see a sort of roughly circular area that was the port of leftist Magna,
not so different from the port of Claudia's,
for example,
at Portas.
Uh,
and then you see the rest of the city as it was laid out from the first century
BC until or through the time of Septum.
You severity.
Uh,
and if you look very carefully,
you will see a host of buildings.
The one that's right in the upper most part,
they're closest to the harbor is the old forum.
It's not on your monument list,
but I'm going to show it to you briefly.
Uh,
if you,
if you go down from that to the left,
you will see the theater that's easy to pick out the theater that was put up,
uh,
during the reign of Augustus.
And to the right of the theater,
you see two circles there.
That is the marketplace that was also put up during the age of Augustus.
Down here you see a very large bath,
uh,
in the imperial bath type that was built during the reign of Hadrian.
And then right above to the right of the bath,
uh,
you see the forum as it was laid out,
the forum,
the basilica and the temple as they were laid out during the reign of symptom
severity.
And then down here to the left of the Patriotic Bads,
there was an arch,
uh,
put up on one of the streets and arch put up also to symptom.
Is Severity,
which we will look at together today.
I want to begin with the Augustan remains.
I'm going to show you to Augusta and buildings from [inaudible].
The first is the markets,
uh,
and the second will be the theater and they're very interesting in all kinds of
ways.
I you see a restored view of what the market would have looked like in the
Augustan period.
This is a restored view,
uh,
that comes from your textbook,
from the Ward Perkins.
Uh,
we know that the building dated precisely to eight BC,
that is in the reign of Augustus eight BC.
How do we know that?
Because there's an inscription on the building,
uh,
that interestingly enough is written in both Latin and then has a neo Punic
translation.
So this is a nod still in the Augustan age two,
the Carthaginian segment of the population who still continued to live there,
even with the Roman,
uh,
advent.
So eight BC,
uh,
and as we look at this,
we know in fact what was built in eight BC was only part of this.
It was the two pavilions,
a two market pavilions that you see in the center here.
This scheme of having a round or round dish,
a structure,
either one or two pavilions in the center of an open courtyard is actually not
special to leftist Magdna.
We know this type in Italy,
they're examples still preserve.
For example,
in Campania I showed you one,
although we didn't discuss it in the plan of the forum upon pay,
uh,
for example.
Uh,
but so this is not,
this is an idea that probably made its way from May of made its way from Italy
to leftist mom in the age of Augustus.
We see it here,
these two pavilions.
But if we look at these pavilions carefully,
we see some interesting features.
We see that the central element is indeed circular.
There's a circular wall here that has in it RQ weighted windows and doorways
that pierce it and open it up.
Then around it though interestingly enough,
we see that the staircase,
uh,
the,
the way in which the columns are arranged,
a and the roof,
uh,
our makeup and octagon make up an octagon.
In the case of both of these pavilions.
Now that is very,
very interesting when we talk about,
uh,
what happens first,
at where in Rome itself campaign here in central Italy or in the provinces.
Because in this particular instance,
we are seeing an octagon extremely early.
This is eight,
eight BC,
the age of Augustus.
We don't see the octagon used in Rome until the age of Nero until the Dome is
trends Vittoria sort of.
And then fully blown,
uh,
in the dome is our e and the octagonal room of the Dome is area.
So is this a formulation that begins first in the provinces and ends up in Rome
or are again,
there's some missing links where they're octagon earlier in Rome that have no
longer survived.
It's an interesting and almost certainly unanswerable question unless something
new is excavated that changes the picture.
So for now it looks as if we see an octagon earlier in the provinces,
then we see it in Rome,
the,
uh,
the while the pavilions and the pavilions were indeed these market pavilions.
And by the way,
I should mention that there were no permanent markets here.
There were temporary stalls that would have been set up daily between the
columns around the pavilions and the columns and the portico.
The open portico was not done in eight BC,
was not done in the age of Augustus,
but was added under type areas.
Augustus,
his successor,
uh,
between,
31 and 37,
as is indicated on your monument list.
And there is a difference in the materials that were used here.
Ah,
and the materials.
Interestingly enough,
and this is very important for our understanding of the evolution of
architecture and leftist Modna.
During this period,
the age of Augustus local stone was used,
uh,
entirely.
Uh,
they used a local sandstone and limestone.
I'll show it to you in a moment,
uh,
for these pavilions.
And then when Tiberias added or when they,
when the outer area,
the Portico was added in the age of Tiberius,
uh,
the columns were made out of a gray stone about a gray stone that was also
local.
So only local stone use two year,
no concrete used in this building.
This is an entirely stone building,
uh,
put up in the Augustan period in leftist Modna,
one of the pavilions,
very well preserved.
As you can see here.
And you can see that we are dealing again with a very attractive local sandstone
or limestone that is used for the instruction for the structure,
for the central pavilions entirely.
Uh,
and then you can see the contrast between the coloration of that and the gray
columns.
Also local stone that are used for the surrounding portico.
If we look at this center,
if we look at this pavilion,
we can see both the central,
the central round element that I've already described with its RQ,
weighted windows and doorways on a tall base.
We can also see the columns that surrounded,
and you can tell very well that these are ionic columns.
Some of them are column,
some of them are in the sense peers.
They're wider and those wider ones are at the corners.
And it's interesting to see how the architects have gotten around the fact that
they have to turn the corners in this octagon,
uh,
by making these wider,
and making them splay out on either side.
You can also see some stone benches in between some,
but not all of the columns here.
And when I did,
I,
let me,
uh,
let me go back for a second just to show you also that the,
um,
that while the columns of the,
uh,
of the pavilions or the Michela by the way,
that's the word in Latin,
Mac,
e l l a or McKellen and Macy,
e l l u m in the singular,
the columns,
the capitals of the,
uh,
surrounding portico were Corinthian as opposed to the ionic ones that are used
for the earlier market pavilions.
Here's another detail.
This is the one that's on your monument list.
Uh,
and although it's in black and white doesn't give you a sense of the coloration
of the stone.
It's useful because you can see one of these piers that turns a corner better
here.
Uh,
and you can also see that there are a strike patients that make up the flutes of
the pilasters that are located in between these arcuate and openings on the
central element.
This is another view that shows you the less,
the less preserved second pavilion.
Uh,
you can see here again the color of the stone.
You can see the way in which the peers turn the corner a here and get a sense of
the remains,
a further sense of the remains of the Augusta marketplace from this view.
The other Augustan building as I mentioned,
was the theater of leftist Magdna and this theater again also put up in the age
of Augustus.
It dates us specifically to a d one,
two,
so a very early Roman theater and a quite well preserved Roman theater.
And we should think of it in connection to the other Augusta enrollment theater
that we saw.
For example,
the theater of Marcellus in Rome.
Uh,
this one as we'll see,
better preserved in some of its aspects.
Then the theater of Marcellus in Rome.
If we look at the plan,
we see some interesting features.
We see first of all a that it is,
it corresponds extremely well to the theaters that we've seen thus far this
semester.
In that sense it's a conventional building.
I should mention that it is not built on a hillside and the Greek manner but is
built on a hill of concrete.
We're going to see that very,
very little concrete is used in lept,
is Magdna is used in uh,
in north Africa enrollment North Africa in general where the work is primarily
of stone.
The buildings are made primarily out of stone,
very little concrete,
but they did use it here,
uh,
to create a hill,
a manmade artificial hill out of concrete on which they could rest,
uh,
the seats of the theater or the coffee of the theater.
The seats themselves are done in local stone,
local stone.
And uh,
we can also see the other features of the typical Roman theater,
the semicircular orchestra,
the semicircular Kava Kava,
the division of the Kavya into these Kunae or wedge sections.
Now we can also see that the stage building,
we know quite a bit about the stage building because it's extremely well
preserved,
uh,
in a way that the theater of Marcellus of course is not.
We see that it was made up of these t three very large,
uh,
niches here that have columns screening the inside following the curvature in
fact of those niches.
And you can also see there are architectural elements in the center here that
seemed to project into that space.
So,
and this is pretty early.
This is a d one to two.
So it does give us some sense.
We,
when we talked about painting,
we talked about the fact that we see things in Roman painting of the second
style in particular 60 BC,
50 BC,
uh,
that we don't see in built architecture.
And I mentioned that that time it's conceivable that they are based on lost
theatrical sets that were made out of wood.
But a building like this where we do have local stone use for the co,
for the,
for this forest of columns that we see inside these niches.
And I'll show it to you cause it's WellPreserved in a moment.
We get it.
We get a sense of the kind of thing that may have existed,
uh,
that may have had some impact on some of the paintings that we saw of the second
style in places like palm pay and elsewhere.
This is also interesting because if you look,
it's hard,
you can't really see it in plan.
But if you look at the very top of the cabi up the top of the coffee and the
center was the location of a temple and that temple was put up to series the
God,
a series a cre s the God has series,
series Agusta.
So the Augustan version of series a and that was at the very top.
And that,
uh,
makes this temple a type of temple that we have not talked about this semester.
And that is what is called a theater temple.
A temple that has a theater that has a temple as an integral part of it.
This is not a new idea to Leptos Moderna.
We know,
for example in Rome that the Republican general pumpy built such a theater in
Rome,
a temple theater,
a theater that had a temple at the apex of the cabiya.
It is not preserved,
although there is enough evidence and fragments and so on for us to get a quite
good sense of what it looked like.
And it was one of these.
So again,
ideas that seemed to have been developed in Rome first are making their way in
this case to left is Magdna notice that the theater at the apex is aligned with
another theater that's located down here.
A large problem,
possibly a larger one a.
And this one,
uh,
this one seems to have been put up to the divine Augustus or to a number of d.
We,
uh,
and uh,
again purposefully aligned with the temple at the top.
Here's something very interesting.
We see the portico us in the back.
This porticoes that we saw,
for example,
at the,
uh,
theater in palm pay,
the early theater in palm pay,
80 to 70 a BC is,
as you'll remember,
a,
we see it here and you can see that it is not as regular as the porticos in palm
pay.
And the reason for that is likely a because of the preexisting buildings on this
site.
And this is where we see a significant difference with the planning of Tim Gat.
Tim Gat.
Again,
the Romans could just lay this out any way they wanted because nothing was
there.
And they chose this ideal costume plan and the theater and so on.
Very,
very regular here they have to contend with earlier structures.
Uh,
they have to bill,
they have to design their building,
keeping those in mind,
they certainly don't want to destroy temples,
for example,
a shrines of the locals that would not be good politics.
So they don't,
uh,
and they have to build their building with that in mind.
And so we see some very unusual shapes here.
It's not what they would've done if they could have done differently,
but they had to do it given the reality of the situation.
This is a view of the,
uh,
theater of Augustus at Leptin smog.
Now as it looks today,
you can see once again that the stone of choice is local stone,
local,
limestone and sandstone,
uh,
for the columns as well as for the car caveat.
But again,
the copy of rests on a concrete foundation and we can see again what I described
before,
the three great niches as well as these square elements with columns that
project into our space that give a very interesting,
uh,
scenic view of columnar architecture.
Uh,
that again gives us an idea of perhaps some of those temporary structures in
wood that would have had a significant impact on second style Roman wall
painting.
This is interesting.
This is an extremely WellPreserved inscription that comes from the theater of
leftist Modna and is still preserved.
Uh,
and we can see here as in the market,
uh,
of Augustus that it is in Latin,
but also translated into neo Punic below.
And I thought you might be interested in hearing what it says a and it says,
and I quote,
and I'll do that in English.
Uh,
when the father of the Father Land Caesar Augustus son of the Deified Caesar,
namely Julius Caesar.
So this is again,
one of the ways we know that this is an Augustan building was Pontifex maximus
that is chief priest of Rome because,
uh,
state and religion very closely allied and the Roman period.
And Augustus was at one point both chief priests of Rome as well as Imparato or
emperor when Augustus was Pontifex maximus vested with the Tribune emission
power for the 24th time being console for the 13th time,
a man by the name of Ana Ball,
Rufus,
the adorn or of his country.
So he must've commissioned not only this,
but other buildings as well,
the adorn or of his country and lover of Concord priest sue feet prefect of the
sacred objects.
The son of him,
of him,
Milko to Papias took care to build this at his own expense and dedicated it.
So here we see a good example of the sort of thing that we see often in the
provinces that is buildings put up in honor of the emperor is during the period
in which they reign,
but put up by major local benefactors who have significant funds,
their disposal who want to do the same sort of thing that anyone who wants to
put their name on a building at Yale is preserved their name for posterity,
their generosity,
their benefaction for posterity.
And at the same time do good,
uh,
by providing the kind of amenities that cities need,
like theaters and baths and the,
like
I mentioned already that a building continue to pace,
uh,
during the time of the emperor Hadrian and the main building that was added to
leftist Magnar during the Adriatic period was a very large bath structure.
The second largest bad structure preserved,
uh,
in Roman North Africa.
And we see it in plan here,
the building block on the right,
uh,
and then a view of a fuller view of the entire bath complex at the left,
it dates to a d 126 to a d 127.
Just looking quickly at the,
uh,
at the,
at the plan over here,
you can see not only the bathing block,
same as we see on the right,
uh,
but also the Polestar of the structure and the Polestar of this structure should
strike you as very different from any other polestar that we've seen thus far
this semester.
It's almost shaped like a hippodrome,
uh,
although it doesn't have the hairpin shape with one curved in one straight end,
but two curved ends.
In fact,
it might remind you more than a hippodrome of the basilica.
Olivia in the forum of Trajan with its two curved ends,
one on either side and columns running around the center,
and then to,
uh,
to radiating is up here on the right on the upper most part.
Excuse me.
Uh,
so at a very unusually shaped Polestar,
we've never seen it Balestra like this before,
but perhaps even more interesting than the shape of the structure is the way
it's off axis with the rest of the building,
right?
It's off axis.
It's not,
it's not,
it's not lined up axially and symmetrically with the rest of the building the
same.
But the reason for that is almost certainly the same as we saw with the port.
It goes in the theater,
the Augustan theater,
and that is something else must have stood on the site that,
that,
that forced them to design this in such a way that it was off center with the
rest of the structure.
But it actually made it,
it makes it more interesting in a sense architecturally with regard to the
bathing block that is very conventional,
you can pick out all the rooms that we've become so accustomed to naming a in
Roman bath architecture.
This is a,
an example of the imperial bath type that we've seen developed in Rome from uh,
the time of Titus,
uh,
up through Trajan,
Baz of Titus and the best suit tray of Trajan,
the imperial bath type where we have the main,
uh,
bathing rooms,
placed in a row in the center of the structure.
Axel axially related to one another.
We see what do we see at the top with the cop,
with the columns around it or the basis and basis.
And then columns above is the what
Natacha than the top Deo.
They
forget Darian
tepid Arrium called Rem Caldari.
I'm here with it's radiating niches as you can see.
So Nataka,
Ato Freakatorium,
tepid,
Doriam called Rem,
all in succession.
And then the other rooms actually symmetrically arranged around them,
duplicated one mirror images of one another on either side.
In this plan,
it doesn't show the frigging Doriam as if it were tripled groin vaulted,
uh,
but most who studied this believe that it was,
the,
and I'll show you a view of that in a moment before I get to that,
a view into the remains of the bads of Hadrian today.
And we see with the bads of Hadrian a very major change in terms of building
stone in the city of leftist Modna.
And that is while up to this point,
they were using entirely local stone all of a sudden in the time of Hadrian.
Uh,
and it's not surprising,
I suppose with Hadrian and his,
his era being a time of international travel and the like internationalism.
Uh,
we see the,
uh,
the,
the beginning to import a marbles from all over the world for,
uh,
the buildings up.
Lept is Magdna.
This being the prime example,
we have building stone in this building.
We have some local stone in this building,
but we also have marble from Greece,
marble from Asia minor and even marble from Italy used in the baths of Hadrian
at leftist Maga.
And making it a very,
very,
quite magnificent building to say the least.
So this a very significant change in the way they are thinking about the
building materials used for the structures of Leptin is here is a restored view
of what scholars,
some scholars at least believe.
Uh,
the [inaudible] of the baths of Hadrian looked like very similar to what we
imagined that the Freekeh Daria have a bas in Rome looked like of the imperial
type of,
think of the later,
the later,
uh,
massive of Caracalla that we looked at last time with the same triple groin
vaulted scheme supported by engaged columns on either side and then very heavily
decorated.
It could be that those who have thought about this have been too influenced by a
spaces like the frigging Daria,
uh,
in,
in the baths of Caracalla.
Uh,
because to do this,
we know that very little concrete was used in leftist magnet to do this kind of
building,
this kind of scale to devote this kind of room at this kind of scale,
you would need to use concrete construction.
So there are two possibilities here.
Either they did use it in this building and used it very well to create a space
that was quite comparable to what was being put up in Rome or it may have been
bolted somewhat differently.
But those who have studied this with,
with some,
you know,
who are not very knowledgeable about this kind of thing,
seemed to believe that this was a groin vaulted building.
Now growing vaults can be done out of material other than concrete.
We saw some,
uh,
some,
um,
vaulting,
uh,
in Pompei,
not growing vaults,
but regular de of vaults in palm pay that were made out of,
out of wood.
But to do it at this scale would be near impossible in one has to imagine that
concrete would have been used.
So that's,
that's controversial and we don't know for sure exactly how this building was
bolted.
Cep Timia severities follows the lead of Hadrian,
uh,
or,
of the,
of,
of those benefactors of leftist modern building buildings in the Adriatic period
by continuing to,
uh,
to have the buildings,
of his renovated home town.
She D in important marbles.
And in fact,
it could be said if,
if,
if CEP,
Timmy is severity,
where to boast as Augustus had before him,
uh,
that he had transformed the city of leftist Magnar.
Instead of saying,
as Augustus did that he found Roma city a brick and left Rome city of marble,
a Septimius Rivera's might've said he found a leftist Magnar,
a city of local limestone and left leftest Magnar,
a city of imported marble because from this time forth,
all of the buildings that we see,
uh,
in the Severin,
a city of lept is Magnar are made out of imported marble.
I'm going to show you a series of these,
uh,
and I'm going to begin first,
oh,
excuse me.
Begin first with the so called fountain or a Nim Fam of the city of leftist
Magna,
which does indeed date to the severance period.
I should,
before I show you that though,
I should mention that we know that September is severity traveled back to
Leptin's once he was emperor of Rome,
but he was involved in,
you'll remember that war and Parthenia,
so he couldn't do it right away.
Uh,
but after the Great Parthian victory,
uh,
and you'll remember the arch in Rome,
the arch of Septum,
you severity in the Roman forum was put up to celebrate that part of the in
victory in 203 and in precisely that same year,
203 [inaudible] Septimius appears to have made his way along with his wife Julia
dominant,
his family,
uh,
to the city of leftist modern,
a hometown boy,
uh,
comes back,
add to great parades and the like for sure.
Uh,
and it also jumpstarted a major,
a building renovation as I've mentioned.
Uh,
and although we think that the arch of me severity in Leptins and I'll show it
to today,
uh,
was put up to,
honor September,
he on his visit to Rome on his visit to leftist Maga and probably stood,
uh,
into o three when he arrived.
We date it to 203.
The other buildings were begun at about that time.
Uh,
and then some of them were completed by his son,
car color after his death.
One of the buildings that belongs to the separate city is this fountain or Nim
Fam that you find on your monument list.
Then in fam in Leptos Magnar that we believe dates a d 211.
You see it here in plan a and you can see it's located next to what?
What's this?
Over here?
Okay.
Uh,
Balestra excellent.
That coffee did you good?
Uh,
that Polestar over here,
uh,
with,
it's projecting a con con [inaudible] here.
Uh,
and we see a on the other side,
the uh,
fam or fountain and you can see how very carefully orchestrated it was in terms
of,
uh,
you know,
making cities,
building cities,
building urban areas.
Uh,
the architects have played a great deal of,
paid a great deal of attention to exactly where they're siting this found in and
its relationship to these other buildings by playing off con cavities against
convex cities and so on.
We can see that the plan,
the plan of the nymph Valium shows it to be a,
a structure that had one large central niche,
which we're going to see had one central apps or niche that had in it,
a series of smaller niches for statuary,
probably images of the emperor and the imperial family as well as important
local magistrates as well as gods and goddesses in front of it.
There was the,
um,
what would be the basin where the water when to water would have flowed out of
the center of the ore,
out of those niches in between the statuary into the base and below.
And you can see the way it's been kind of splayed off to either side to give it
an interesting shape and to make it seem a very welcoming.
Now why did a city like leftest modern and need a fountain of this magnitude?
Well,
yes,
it did supply water,
uh,
that it was helpful in that regard.
But I think it was much more than that.
I think it was viewed as a kind of showpiece,
uh,
for the city that there came a time when every city worth its salt needed to
have a showpiece like this,
an ostentatious fountain,
a leftist was no example.
Uh,
and so they build such an Austin Sacious fountain in the,
in the seven period in leftist Magnar.
Here's a view of part of it.
As it looks today,
it's actually decently WellPreserved.
Uh,
and we can see,
uh,
the,
one of,
we can see the great niche or part of the great niche here with it's great apps
here with it's a smaller niches for statuary as I've described.
We can also see that we are dealing here with regard to the walls with local
sandstone or limestone being used for the wall construction.
But all of the columns,
and you can see a columnar scheme here on two stories,
a very similar to the sort of thing that we saw in the theater.
Uh,
a display of columns a and they go,
they go into the niches as well.
As you can see here,
uh,
in two tears,
these are made out of marble.
That is brought in from minor Asia minor marble.
So imported marble.
And we do believe that the,
uh,
the stone carvers who were,
who were used to carving this kind of marble in Asia minor were brought in with
them to do the carving on the spot.
So one of these examples of the use of imported marble in buildings that were
put up in Severen leftist Magdna,
I mentioned that I would show you just in passing the old forum of leftist
Magnar before we look at the sovereign forum.
Just so that you know,
it's not a new monument list.
You're not responsible for it,
although it is in Ward Perkins and you can read about it there.
Uh,
but I show it to,
to make a couple of very important points.
One that there was an earlier forum on this site.
It was begun in the late republic and continued into the Augustan period.
It was laid out very close to the port,
which,
which makes a lot of sense.
Uh,
and uh,
you can see that like other four are,
we've seen it had a great open rectangular space.
It had a basilica,
uh,
down here,
very similar in shape and plan to bacillus cause we've seen like the one at palm
pay.
Uh,
but it's interesting both because again,
it is not exactly a square or rectangular in shape.
It has one,
a one side that is different from that.
It's on a diagonal.
And this indicates to us,
once again that likely there were some remains on the site,
uh,
that had to be taken into consideration when this structure was designed.
But otherwise it has a colonnade around it.
It has,
in this case,
three temples on one end,
which is different from what we usually see in Rome,
but not unheard of.
I didn't show you an example of what we do know of triple temples,
uh,
in,
in architectural spaces,
complexes in Rome,
a fairly early on already in the republic,
but we see three of them here and they're very instructive ones.
The North Temple,
we don't know to whom that was dedicated.
The other is a temple of Roma and Augustus,
which one sees in most Augustan cities.
Uh,
and then over here,
a temple of Liebherr pot tear who was Liebherr pot tear will leave bear pot.
There was a god who was very important to this particular part of the world.
So this interesting coming together of Roman gods.
Local gods are a another indication that we are dealing here with a Roman
society that is being laid on top of an earlier society and that the,
that the cultures,
religion,
uh,
architectural practices and so on of them merged together to make a very
interesting may launch.
And we see that again extremely well in this old forum.
The old forum was replaced by the new forum,
the new Severen forum in the age of Septum,
Mya severities.
And that is the single most important building is still surviving in the city of
a building complex in the city of leftist Magdna.
And I show you once again that view from the air of the forum,
the Severin Forum that we believe dates to 216,
a d in fact completed by Caracalla in 216 and I,
and now that you know a bit more about Leptos Spadina and building practice
there,
I think you'll see something that you probably didn't notice before when you
looked at this image when we looked at it earlier.
And that is a,
if you look at the actual,
um,
remains of the columnar architecture,
for example,
from this forum,
you will see very quickly that we are dealing not with local limestone but with
imported marble.
If you look at this marble in the foreground in particular,
you can see that it has a pink tint to it.
Uh,
that pink tint tells us that it is a,
it is a granite pink granite,
uh,
that we know was quarried and Egypt.
So we are seeing marbles being brought from all over the world,
uh,
to be used in the construction of these Severen structures.
A plan of the AH,
Severen forum in leftist magna shows it to be a very interesting structure.
Indeed.
One that is based on earlier models in Rome is especially the forum of Trajan,
uh,
but one that departs from it in all kinds of interesting ways.
It's also interesting to us,
not only because it tells us what are,
it shows us what was being built in Severen Magdna,
but it also gives us some indication of what a,
an emperor likes up Timmy severes might have built in Rome if he had built a
forum in Rome.
You'll remember that I told you the last great imperial forum in Rome was the
forum of Trajan and there was no other forum built later than that.
But what if you know,
the,
what if,
uh,
September he has had said severs had build,
Bill had built a forum and basilica in Rome.
What would it have looked like?
Well,
maybe it would've looked something like this,
at least in plan,
but almost certainly not in building materials.
As we look at it here,
we see that it is conventional in that is very large in scale.
By the way,
it's conventional in that it has one great open rectangular space surrounded by
columns with a temple put up against one of the short walls,
in fact pushed up against one of the short walls dominating the space in front
of it.
If we look quickly at the plan of the temple,
we will see it's fairly conventional.
Also plain back wall single seller in this case a freestanding columns in the
port deep porch,
single staircase facade orientation.
So very much in keeping with what we've seen throughout the course of the
semester.
You'll notice also on this side of the structure of the southern side of the
structure,
a series of shops or to bear and I,
we've seen that in forum design before.
Think of the form of Julius Caesar,
uh,
where they were placed in exactly that same position we see over here the
basilica of the structure.
I'm not going to describe,
it's planned for the moment.
We'll return to it a little bit later.
But what's interesting about it here is the way in which it is splayed off it is
not actually related exactly to the,
uh,
to the forum proper.
Uh,
it moves off in a slightly different direction with the Romans have done this.
If they didn't have to,
certainly not a,
they probably again had to contend with some sort of earlier building on the
site,
which forced them to do this.
But they've done something quite extraordinary as you can see here.
They wanted to make sure that when you were standing in the forum and looking
toward the basilica,
that you wouldn't realize that that basilica was not on axis with the forum.
And so they've done something extraordinarily ingenious.
And what they've done is to create this series,
this wedge shaped series of shops that forms the transition between the forum
and the basilica that's narrow on,
went in and is wider on the other end.
And when you stand and look at it from the inside,
and I'll show you an image in a moment,
it looks like it is completely straight,
which it is in the front.
Uh,
but you can't tell what lies behind.
So when you're standing there,
you do get the sense and as you move from the forum,
uh,
into this niche apps area here through columns into the columns of the basilica,
which you can do a,
you don't realize that the basilica is really off axis with the rest of the
building.
So some ingenious work here on the part of the designers of the separate forum.
I'll come back to the basilica again momentarily,
but for the moment,
just to stick with the forum proper,
uh,
we are looking here at one of the entrance ways into that forum.
Uh,
and you can see even in black and white that we're dealing with local sandstone
or limestone for the walls,
uh,
but with,
imported marble for the doorways and for the pilasters.
And if you look very carefully,
you will see that these are capitals that are unlike any capital's we've seen
thus far this semester.
And,
and underscore again this interesting merging of influences,
not only from Rome but elsewhere in the Roman empire.
We see these striatum,
the striatum capital's on the pilasters up above that are very similar to the
sorts of things we see in Egypt.
Uh,
and then if we look at these capitals down below and we see these capitals used
extensively in the forum,
I'll show you other examples momentarily.
You will see that what we are dealing with here are the Roman a can't this
leaves at the bottom.
But growing out of those Roman a canvas leaves are lotus leaves,
Lotus leaves,
uh,
that come from Egypt,
a lotus leaves that were used in Egyptian capitol.
So this interesting merging of Roman culture,
Egyptian culture,
uh,
for this structure in a Roman north Africa.
This is a view of the shops of that wedge shape section of shops were standing
in the forum looking back toward the basilica about to go from one to the other
and you can see that they are in a straight line and that you would not be able
to tell as you were standing in front of them.
Uh,
that the,
uh,
forum was not actually related to,
the basilica next door.
We can also see some remains of statuary columns preserved in their entirety as
well as capitols of the same type that I just showed you.
The combination of Lotus leaves and a canvas leaves the temple,
the temple in this,
uh,
the temple here is the one that you see here.
It is a restored view.
It is from Ward Perkins is a temple that was put up by Caracalla.
Uh,
it's this the temple at the back wall that we looked at and plan just before it
was put up by Caracalla to honor his parents as a due,
uh,
September.
The severity and Julia Domino.
It's interesting in a variety of ways.
It's interesting because it is surrounded by a,
an arcade columns supporting occupations.
We've seen an interest in this sort of thing,
uh,
starting to come to the fore at,
at this time we saw it in late domestic architecture in Ostia.
Think of the house of cupid and psyche for example,
of the early fourth century.
So placing these arcades on columns with Medusa heads in between them is
something that comes to the fourth.
This time.
Uh,
we see that the temple is placed on a very,
very tall podium,
19 feet tall.
Why?
To raise it up over the walls so that you could see it from a distance.
It's like they,
when they raise the to Liam and Ostia also up high so that it could compete with
the apartment houses.
The same general idea here.
Local limestone for the walls,
imported marble for the columns.
Uh,
the,
um,
uh,
the staircase is interesting.
It's a single staircase,
but you can see it as parameter all in shape.
I don't want to push the Egyptian thing too far,
but it's conceivable that it might've been designed under Egyptian influence.
And if you look at the column bases,
we know that they were depicted with images of the battle between God's and
giants.
A,
uh,
a very important theme in Greek art.
Uh,
so we see,
once again,
what's so interesting about some of these provincial cities,
this coming together of influences from all over the world,
from Greece,
from Carthage,
from Egypt,
and also of course from Rome.
Here's a view of the arcades.
The Medusa's heads,
very deeply carved a,
as you can see here,
characteristic also of the decorative work of the severance period.
Uh,
the plan,
once again that shows us the,
uh,
the basilica central nave side aisles apses on either side,
looking very much like the Basilica Olivia of Trajan in Rome.
Uh,
probably influenced by that look.
Also you,
there's a wall here.
You can walk into the wall at several points and there are columns decorating
that wall.
Columns that just project into our space.
They have no structural purpose whatsoever.
The in and out a undulation of the wall through the traditional vocabulary of
architecture.
Uh,
another sign that we're moving toward what I've called a baroque phase,
uh,
in a Roman antiquity.
This is an amazing view from the air of the remains of the forum and also the
basilica.
The basilica is better preserved than the forum.
Uh,
the basilica and you can see how beautifully this is cited right near the sea.
Again,
we're dealing with a port here,
port city here.
You can see the apps is,
you can see the preserve columns.
You can see the wedge shape section of shops here.
Uh,
and uh,
you can see again that the basilica has many of its columns better preserved
than those in the forum.
We see them here.
Uh,
we can get a much better sense of what the basilica looked like in antiquity.
In fact,
this is much better preserved than the Basilica Olivia in Rome.
We see the,
and we see the difference in the materials.
The pink granite from Egypt used here as well.
Uh,
the Corinthian,
in this case,
Corinthian capitals rather than the Po.
The Lotus leaf capital's a sandstone for the wall.
So this combination of local stone and especially imported marbles for this
structure.
Here's a restored view of the interior,
uh,
where we can see it was two storied originally,
just like the Basilica Olympian Rome,
like the basilica opion Rome,
a flat ceiling with a co,
a coffered ceiling.
As you can see above.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we can also see the niches have coughing in them.
Very interesting decoration,
use of columns on two tiers,
no structural purpose whatsoever.
Decorative only projecting into our space,
creating that in and out undulating movement.
And then a very unusual motif,
architectural motif in the center.
I show you here the south apps where we can see the pink granite once again,
preserve a ionic capitals in this particular case for that niche.
And then these very heavily decorated pilasters on either side,
uh,
and in the center of the niche,
these very tall columns.
This is very interesting because it seems to have had no purpose whatsoever.
Then just to stand there and look good to colossal columns on tall basis,
uh,
with Corinthian capitals and then a lintel on top of those.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
Griffin's uh,
and then another lintel on the top.
What was the purpose of this?
Did it have some kind of religious purpose?
While this is a civic structure,
so unlikely,
it's just a decoration among other decorations,
but using architectural elements in toto,
the peers are very,
very interesting.
They're eaten away.
D materialized by their sculpture as you can see here,
light and dark,
uh,
accentuated.
And if you look at the details of them,
you will see that one of them are a couple of them have scenes of the uh,
of the 12 labors of Hercules.
Remember this was a building that was completed by Caracalla.
Is it a stretch to say,
uh,
that Caracalla a or might have wanted to have her Kuli and imagery here as he
did in the baths of Caracalla or the benefactor who helped us build this.
Might have had that in mind as well to make that connection might be far
fetched,
but certainly something worth thinking about and to more details of that
decoration here I want to mention just in passing,
uh,
the arch of Septimius severities.
It's more work of sculpture than it is an architecture and it has a lot of
figural scenes that are interesting for their iconography.
But I just want to make passing reference to it because it is the one building
that I mentioned that we do believe was put up in two oh three a and ready for
Septimius his visit to the city.
It also is interesting because it is,
it is,
it was made at the same time as the arch in Rome,
the Parthian arch in Rome,
203,
eight d and also celebrates,
uh,
Septimius saveras his victories over the Parthians.
That's exactly what it celebrates in the scenes are alluded to in the figural
sculpture,
but it is very different from the arch in Rome because it is a tech trap lot.
I mentioned the tech trap alum and we went over the paper topics,
the four sided arch,
the purpose of which is to span two streets that cross at that,
that intersect at that particular point so that traffic can go through the arch
going both ways.
It's really quite ingenious.
And we see the Ted Trap,
Alon does not,
does not take off in Rome,
but it's very popular in the provinces and we see it here.
We also see as we look at this structure and it has been,
um,
by the way,
it had fallen down completely but has been redirected.
Although the sculpture on it,
uh,
is,
is casts and the original sculpture in the museum.
But we do see here something very interesting and that is that they have used
the broken triangular pediment here.
You can see the way the pediment is broken apart and used a used only in part
here,
which is something we do not see.
Uh,
in,
um,
Roman arch design.
Here's a view of it from the side where you can get a sense of the drama of
those broken triangular pediments as well as the way in which this structure was
completely covered with a sculpture.
And you can see some of that sculpture also d materializing the arch in a way
very similar to the peers that we saw also in the basilica.
And I just show you too quickly to details of the figural sculpture that we see.
They're honoring Septimus severities and his two sons in a triumphal chariot at
the top.
And then down here below Septimus shaking hands with his elder son Caracalla as
if giving him a power gave us stands in the center gate is still alive and not
erased on this monument here.
Uh,
and uh,
but gave us standing here and then this wonderful image of Julia Domino with her
fabulous wig,
a standing next to them and looking on a,
but look at this figure here.
Who is this Hercules with his club standing right behind the shoulder of
Caracalla.
So once again,
this very close association between Cora Koller and his alter ego.
I want to end today with my favorite building.
And left is Magdna,
in fact one of my favorite buildings from the entire semester because it's so
unique.
This is the so called hunting baths at Leptos Magnar they date to the late
second to uh,
early third century.
And I show you an accident metric view from ward Perkins are very well preserved
and I'll show you,
show them to you in a moment.
This bath is interesting in all kinds of ways,
but it's interesting primarily because it's a private bath,
not a public bath.
We've looked at so many public buses semester.
What do I mean by a private bath?
Not One individual.
I suppose one could call Hadrian's bads in his villa private and that they were
for his private villa.
Uh,
but,
but here a private bath within a city,
uh,
a private bed,
not for a single individual,
but a group of individuals,
a guild of men whose job,
whose profession we believe it was to collect animals,
wild animals in the wilds of Africa,
and uh,
send them to Italy.
That was their business.
Send them to feed in a sense the amphitheaters of Rome and the rest of Italy.
That was their job.
They probably make quite a fortune doing that.
And they got together and built for themselves is wonderful bath,
which you're going to see right near the sea where they could kick back and
relax and hang out with each other.
And what a place it was a,
and what's interesting about it is,
although we have seen that concrete was not used extensively in leftist Mondo,
it is used for this building and this building is much more innovative for that
reason.
Then most of the other structures we've seen,
even those that honors Septum,
you saveras like the arch,
like the forum and like the basilica.
What do I mean by innovative?
You can see the way in which,
uh,
concrete has been used here to its utmost.
You'll enter into the structure.
The forecourt is an octagon.
The entrance vestibule is an octagon for the entrance vestibule.
You go into the tip of Dorian,
which you can see has a segmented Doma kind of Pumpkin don't,
uh,
influenced by those earlier ones of Hadrian into the Caldari him over here,
which is large and barrel vaulted,
the frigate Dory.
I'm also barrel vaulted here as you can see,
but what makes these,
these rooms particularly exciting architecturally and different than anything
we've seen in fact unique is that not only can we see the shapes of these vaults
on the concrete bolts on the inside when we stand here,
but also from the outside,
the shapes are visible from the outside as well.
You can see from the outside that this was a barrel vaulted rooms.
You can see from the outside that this was a barrel vaulted room and you can see
from the outside that this one had a segmented dome.
Uh,
we haven't seen that in other architecture.
Yes,
you can get a little glimmer of it.
When you look at the frigging Daria of the great imperial Baz in Rome,
you didn't get a sense of the groin vaults from,
from the outside,
sort of a but not in the way that you can hear.
This is very revolutionary,
very different,
uh,
and uh,
very special to this particular building.
And I'll show you two last images where you can see that also from the outside,
this one in black and white.
And you can see the massing of these geometric forms from the outside,
which make very clear what lies inside.
Very clear,
the member,
the Pantheon with,
it's surprised you standing outside.
It looks like a typical Greek Greek temple.
You walk inside,
wow,
it's a,
it's a Roman interior here.
It's inside and outside are brought together in a way that we haven't seen
before.
When you stand at the outside of this building and look at it,
you can tell what those shapes are like on the inside in a way that we have not
seen before.
A truly revolutionary building.
And I show you one last image.
It's faded,
but it's the best I've got.
And it's a really,
it's a really,
I think,
very effective image in terms of showing you what these bats look like,
silhouetted against the sand and the see the barrel vaults,
the segmented vaults,
all of those,
uh,
clearly revealed on the outside as they were on the inside.
A very innovative structure put up,
not by the emperor,
not by the reigning emperor,
not by benefactors who wanted to honor the emperor and not part of that great
Severen renovation,
but part of the individual hearts and minds of this particular group of men.
And what can I say to end this lecture except for those men in the late second,
early third century.
A d life was good.
Thank you.
All.